all right this is super interesting
yesterday on the program the view there
was a confrontation between two former
trump staffers the very well-known
kellyanne conway and the slightly less
well-known alissa farah griffin they
both previously worked for trump at
different points in time this is a
complete train wreck of a conversation
where they start going at each other uh
let's just let's just jump into it and
uh then we'll discuss because it is
fascinating do you want to acknowledge
something you said last segment um i
remember flying on air force one in
october of 2020 and two very senior
advisors to the president dave bossie
and corey lewandowski turned to me and
said we would be winning this race if it
was kellyanne running the campaign so i
think that there's there's some real
truth to the direction it went the
second time around and that perhaps you
having a more senior role would have
changed that um but i have to ask you
something we served together um briefly
in the white house my second time i
admired you the first time when i was
working for pence you were very helpful
what happened the second time oh the
second time no i just met i looked up to
you i wasn't you're in more comparable
roles i was a bit more junior role the
first time um i broke with the president
ahead of january 6 when the big lie
started being shared i resigned in
december december 4th and i spoke out
after january 6 when i saw a violent mob
assault the capital question in here yes
okay um
how how do you is there a question in
here so it starts to get testy and
kellyanne clearly doesn't like the
direction this is going to still defend
him do you still think he could be a
good president after he tried to
overturn our democracy okay so i left
three months before you did for my
children i have four of them and i i
said less drama more mama and that's
exactly what i did i think you stayed a
whole month after the election that you
were having a problem with but that's i
wanted to help my junior staff get jobs
i think people should know that because
i haven't seen you since you've changed
but i want to say this to you i didn't
change just to be clear i didn't change
i swore i don't know
you shouldn't hear every day i swear to
the constitution not to donald trump i
know but alyssa i know that you right as
we all did
as we all did but um and i i appreciate
that i think there was a lot wrong with
the 2020 campaign and i think in in
addition to that afterwards your former
boss mark meadows who was a terrible
chief of staff not matching the man did
not match the moment look at this this
is just everybody pointing the finger at
each other for what went wrong this this
is the rats abandoning the ship for a
global pandemic a re-election campaign
neither did that excuse me protest after
george george floyd's murder he didn't
match the moment at all and didn't take
advice but do you think donald trump
matched them and then he allowed he
allowed supplicant after sycophant after
showman to come before the resolute desk
and promise the president that was the
day they were going to find more votes
in arizona wisconsin pennsylvania
so this is fascinating because kellyanne
is basically saying it was mark meadow's
fault that trump ended up believing all
this stuff about the big lie it wasn't
trump himself now of course personal
responsibility if trump
if if this story is true
isn't it trump's responsibility
ultimately to vet whether mark meadows
is really telling him the truth
you know i was on david so i'll answer
your question maybe you missed it i was
on abc live on january 6th
and
that's
said people have to get out of the
capital what are you doing there why
have you reached the capitol what is
going on
but you're still supporting donald trump
now live on january 6. alyssa if you're
saying that
somehow you think
we're supposed to think that you've seen
the light and not just see your name and
lights that's not fair
you're not answering
the question
president joe biden i know but you're
talking about maybe a second term you've
never denounced donald trump that's when
he incited a violent mob that i did that
day first of all i didn't but then you
went right back too okay so what we're
going to do right now is we're going to
move on because we're going to go to the
question do me a favor because we don't
have as much time as we did so answer
the question to do this do you like
working with me i'm sorry
don't make me important
go on um
on january 6th and people get the hell
out of your question all right i don't
want the 74 million
it's just really a follow-up to that
question so so a complete and total
train wreck and listen the there's a lot
of uh uh kind of posturing here in her
new book kellyanne conway levy's some
uh tell some
complicated stories about her
involvement and everybody now is
essentially trying to rewrite history in
the way that most advantages them uh but
what is very clear is that everybody's
pointing fingers at each other and just
a complete train wreck of a view episode
interesting to see
as i've said many times before i believe
that the secret to
personal finance and it's not really a
secret isn't about timing the market or
picking individual stocks it's basically
asset allocation and in order to
determine asset allocation you've got to
know all of the different assets that
are out there that's why i joined a
community called alts and we asked them
to be a sponsor
alts is a newsletter that makes the
world of alternative assets accessible
to anyone even if you're new to it alt
does the research on alternative assets
that no one else is doing right now and
they break it down for readers in a way
that's nuanced and it's easy to digest
and honest and provides you with just a
ton of valuable insight into
what assets are there and this could be
baseball cards collectibles music rights
comic books video games the alts
newsletter demystifies
these investment markets for you their
recommendations have a track record that
you can check out on their website
and you can also learn about the alts
one fund which contains a blend of
alternative assets including
collectibles and art and music rights
and the things that i've mentioned you
can find that and the free newsletter at
davidpakman.com
alts the link is down below